Ninja did an oopsie
Alinity did an oopsie
Tekashi69 did a big oopsie
and Smosh oopsie
My name is Gloria Borger, Oopsie Doopsie. lets bring on the news
Pew News the most respected news source on Youtube.
this just in
everyone hates ninja now
why?
cause he's basically Pewdiepie 2015
unfunny
screaming
loud
obnoxious
unselfaware
coloured hair *chuckles*
NO
because ninja gets people banned
that's right everybody
if ninya (swedish accent coming thorugh) doesnt like you on fortnite, he can get you banned.
*snaps* like that, he is the Thanos of fortnite
this all started because uh on uh reddit, a post said that
This player is about to get banned because he emoted